[Music]
we're all started as an internet joke
that ended up getting global attention
hundreds of alien hunters and gathered
in Nevada near the government facility
known as area 51 might remember arpel
built a career on talking about this all
in an effort to quote storm the military
base these two people were reportedly
detained earlier today they were events
last night and today we sent our own
lawrence Jones to find out what the
extra-terrestrial believers were doing
out in the Nevada desert we hope he's
not been abducted
take a look why are you here are you
here for scientific reasons here for
scientific reasons we're here for the
aliens oh you know I want to hear about
the alien liberal agenda they could have
some good talking point we don't know
when did you first discover your alien
[Music]
blowing your head this hat is to protect
my mind from interference of any kind
now yet but we're hoping you're hoping I
gonna store there you won I want to have
you guys had any interaction with the
outside world today no yesterday also no
kind that we had somewhere dreams of the
night before I joining us now from
Nevada
he is our official 2020 on-the-ground
reporter an investigative reporter as
well Lawrence Jones glad to see you have
not been abducted I'm looking at this
these are real believers I don't have a
problem with it at all I don't know the
majesty of God's creation if we know
those universes within universes I just
don't know hey son I'm in heiko Nevada
at the alien Research Center earlier
today we had the opportunity to talk to
some people some of them believe it some
people believe that they just wanted to
have a good time area 51 is actually
Lawrence spaceship I think just away
from here Lawrence what's that behind
you look like a spaceship for a minute
but I guess it's a car well you know you
got all type of stuff flying behind the
Sun do you know everybody's try to go in
and see aliens and stuff but again a lot
of these people believe it a lot of
these people are like the Comicon crew
they just want to have a good time it
was over 2,000 people at the first event
that we were at today so they're keep
coming on in I mean is their main thing
that they believe and I've watched
enough The History Channel etc the
NatGeo has a whole special I watched on
area 51 once I love documentaries I want
to know what other people think but they
really believe a lot of people that
there are UFOs have been unidentified
flying objects and people have landed
from other planets and they have a they
claimed to have been abducted you meet
any of those people
I met some of those people I've met some
people today too said that ever since
they've been here they felt the ground
shaking and they feel like they're it's
because they're so close to the facility
that they're getting all this
interference one lady believed that her
parents is actually aliens you have one
lady that said that she allegedly worked
at area 51 and she knows this stuff to
be true so all right a lot of people
with conflicting experience that some
people just want to drink and have a
good time
Lawrence thank you